[Musique]
laure castro royal de la police de
barbade présent à tous les gros
événements du pays est en répétition
avec les forces en mai pour la
commémoration de l'armistice
la cérémonie pour rendre hommage aux
soldats morts dont les deux grandes
guerres à lyon à bridgetown capital de
barbade
les recrues barbadienne ont combattu
pour la grande bretagne dont barbade fut
une colonie
fondée en 1889 l'orchestra maintient une
tradition de discipline et de rigueur
l'emplacement de chaque musicien est
décidée par le tambour major le sergent
d'un basque âme sous les ordres du
directeur donc astra surintendant
principal john lynch
[Musique]
l'eau castres ses rangs au centre des
cérémonies du 30 novembre 2021 le jour
où barbade deviendra une république la
reine d'angleterre actuel chef des temps
du pays sera remplacé par un président
élu par le parlement tout tombe lem de
la royauté disparaîtra alors des
costumes de lancastre le mont royal sera
effacée
d'abord notre drapeau va quitter le
défilé
ensuite nous allons présenter notre
nouveau drapeau présidentiel la couronne
sera remplacé par les armoiries de la
barbade
quand on deviendrait république on sera
vraiment indépendant
nous serons toujours des habits de
londres est des états unis
mais toutes les responsabilités de la
reine seront transmises à notre
président
[Musique]
la caserne de sainte cécile y en ait le
siège de l'anc est royan de la police de
barbade tous les jours les musiciens
passent devant le blason ailé pente
raide et ancien directeur ou de musique
jazz raison william grizzlies et
prennent ce qu'eva sans quelques noms
qui ont dirigé les orchestres dont le
passé des maillon dans une chaîne de
langue tradition
[Musique]
où
la salle mardi ce morceau intitulé la
mairie sous la neige est dédié aux
soldats morts dans les deux guerres
mondiales
la marine britannique et tous les
orchestres anglais le jeu c'est un
hommage à ceux qui sont
le tambour-major le sergent d'un vaste
gamme à intégrer l'orchestré il y à 22
ans formé par la police lui et les 50
autres membres du groupe sont musiciens
à temps plein leurs instruments ont dû
être rangés pendant la pandémie de covè
19 tout doucement les répétitions
reprennent dans l'auditorium de la
caserne cet orchestre d'origine
colonialiste s'est transformé en une
entité sans peau sont barbadienne
[Musique]
on joue presque tous les genres de
musique
nous ne renonçons jamais à nos racines
classiques
mais on joue le jazz
le reggae
et notre musique locale unc habib sow
nous avons nous a donné dans le passé
nous avons transformé
nous avons ajouté nos propres rythmes
nos formes d'expression et c'est devenu
quelque chose qui nous sont chères
[Musique]
pour aider l'armée du salut art côté des
fonds lancastre se produit en concert au
centre-ville de bridgetown pour cette
prestation les manceaux sont des
compositions barbadienne
[Musique]
cette chanson appelait à bolton l'oeuvre
d'un grand calibre sonia déplorent la
destruction d'un quartier populaire du
pays
[Musique]
à barbade le jour de l'indépendance le
30 novembre en 1966 est une date de
fierté nationale
les vitrines de la capitale bridgetown
met à l'honneur les couleurs et les
personnalités du pays
les merceries vendent des tissus aux
couleurs nationales bleu et jaune pour
satisfaire une clientèle qui veut
s'habiller jusqu'aux ongles en drapeau
national
je suis fier d'être barbadienne fiers de
ce que nous avons accompli en tant que
petit pays tellement fier j'ai fait tout
ce qu'il faut c'est et je fais de jean
bad
depuis 20 ans chaque novembre madame
salma corps ou vanseb brochand ruban et
ses bracelets aux couleurs de son pays
cette année est encore plus importante
qu'à barbade se transforme en république
a j'ai hâte qu'on devienne une
république
j'attends ça parce que nous sommes fiers
d'être caribéen fier d'être barbadien et
on a besoin d'avancer
pendant plus de 360 barbade a été une
possession de la couronne britannique
durant cette période l'aristocratie
anglaise a fait fortune dans le sucre
cultivée avec le label gratuit et forcé
des esclaves la reine elizabeth a
effectué plusieurs visites officielles
sur cette île baptisée la petite
angleterre des antilles à chaque
déplacement la population alignés au
bord des routes à agiter les drapeaux
britanniques avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé
en 1966 et robert au père de
l'indépendance héros national et premier
premier ministre de barbade annonce
qu'il est temps d'arrêter de flâner dans
les locaux coloniaux sa statue est
érigée sur la place de l'indépendance
dans la capitale
mais au moins pendant les cinquante cinq
ans qui ont suivi l'indépendance
la reine d'angleterre a conservé son
statut de chef d'état de barbade
aujourd'hui son rompre ses liens
commerciaux et diplomatiques avec la
grande-bretagne
barbade se défait de ses derniers alliés
en coloniaux
la nomination d'un président le nouveau
chef d'état un rôle plutôt honorifique a
été validé par les membres de la
législature barbadienne son excellence
la présidente madame st jo mais ce n'est
par ailleurs la première femme avocate
de barbade est la première femme juge à
la cour d'appel du pays proche du peuple
elle a même autorisé la présence des
médias quand elle se fait vacciner
contre la coved 19 c'était sa façon
d'encourager les barbadiens à se
protéger contre les virus
je voulais qu'on me croit quand j'ai dû
hériter vacciner
que c'était un exercice ans
et sans aucune
c'est ici à l'assemblée nationale de
barbade que le changement de statut a
été voté à l'unanimité par la chambre
des députés et le sénat
lévesque joseph poli de l'église
chrétienne de la caraïbe est l'unique
membre de l'opposition à la chambre des
députés
à ses lauriers je m'assois ici ma place
et le premier siège à la gauche du
président de la chambre des députés
je suis ici en face de moi c'est le
premier ministre dont le siège est à la
gouache du président
les règlements parlementaire encore
basée sur le modèle britannique ont été
révisés pour permettre à la nomination
d'un président
l'élaboration de la nouvelle
constitution de la république commencera
en 2022
pour la première fois en nous un chef
d'état qui né à bagdad et qui n'est pas
le représentant de la reine d'angleterre
est
ce important
attendons ce moment depuis quand même
pour échapper à la solitude être
l'unique membre de l'opposition
n'avaient qu'un théorie sent souvent de
son bureau
habillés en costume cravate hisser
dirigent vers la mer pour se changer les
idées et rencontre les gens sur la plage
il m'a dit vous avez passé
il m'a dit que je portais la face de
dieu sur moi il me l'a dit
je suis un chrétien depuis près de
treize ans et chaque fois que je
rencontre un frère ou une soeur dans le
clip il ya toujours une collection
député depuis plus de 20 ans ont des
1018 sans parti a remporté les
législatives avec une majorité absolue
l'avait quaterly décide donc de quitter
la majorité pour endosser le rôle de
leader de l'opposition
nous faut une opposition à barbade nos
pratiques démocratiques et culturel
l'exigent
il faut
c'est pourquoi j'ai quitté mon parti
politique
mais il n'a aucune marge de manoeuvre
ses efforts pour faire changer la date
du cassage en république ont été rejeté
c'est l'essence même d'une république
qui font possession du pouvoir dans le
pays et fait l'événement d'une manière
spectaculaire aujourd'hui avec le coup
vide beaucoup de personnes sont au
chômage les gens souffrent de dépression
ils sont touchés psychologiquement
en plus les rassemblements sont
interdits
à 14 ans la collégienne cédrid l'une des
plus brillantes de sa promotion se
penche aussi sur le changement de statut
de son pays
dont quatre ans elle sera en âge de
voter aux élections législatives
la coved 19 a bouleversé sa vie les
écoles sont fermées et ça fait cinq mois
qu'elle vient chez ses grands-parents
poursuivre c'est qu'on en ligne elle ne
voit plus ses amis
depuis son jeune âge elle suit
l'actualité locale si elle soutient le
principe de la transition vers une
république elle cherche plus
d'information sur l'impact de ce
changement
lui de nous annoncer simplement que nous
allons devenir une république et que
c'est comme ça on devrait nous donner
plus de précisions pas seulement les
explications théoriques
il faut nous expliquer en termes simples
pour que tout le monde peu importe le
niveau de scolarité puisse comprendre
son père tel reid informaticiens ou
gouvernement suit la progression de sa
fille qui veut devenir ingénieur
il la motive dans son travail malgré l'
isolement qui pèse sur toute la famille
à l'âge de huit ans à sa demande son
père l'a amené dont des réunions
politiques pour écouter les discours
elle a des idées claires à concernant le
développement de son pays
il y a toujours des échanges avec sydney
pour essayer de lui expliquer les
concepts fondamentaux du fonctionnement
d'un gouvernement
n'est pas facile
nous la jeunesse en grandissant vous
vous lancez unités à l'échelle
internationale pour faire comprendre que
peu importe la petite superficie de
notre pays nous sommes capables
d'apporter des contributions précieuses
aux affaires nationale
au musée national de barbade beaucoup de
familles barbadienne passionnés par
leurs histoires deviennent apprendre à
l'évolution sociale de leur île les
enfants de la famille gooden qui
visitent le musée régulièrement sont
fascinés par le passé
nous étions ici il ya un mois on a
visité le musée enfants on a juste
traversé cette pièce mais ils ont
tellement aimé que j'étais surprise
aujourd'hui on emmener mon neveu au
musée des enfants et on est passés ici
encore ils sont aussi enthousiasmé
j'aime découvrir les différents types
d'appareils que les gens utilisaient
dans le temps
l'exposition de l'évolution sociale des
barbes indien commencé avec les
atrocités faites aux esclaves dont
beaucoup ont été marqués par les fer
brûlant
la vitrine sur le système judiciaire
montre que jusqu aux années 30 on
autorise l utilisation du fouet comme
punition
à la
conservatrice du musée explique
l'éducation a été le moteur de la
mobilité sociale des barbes indien à
l'indépendance en 1966 la scolarité
jusqu'à 16 ans est devenu obligatoire
pour aider les familles les fournitures
scolaires le transport et la comptine
ont été pris en charge par l'état
la vie s'est tellement améliorée il est
important de comprendre d'où on est
sortis par rapport à maintenant pour les
élèves les adultes et les visiteurs les
jeunes peuvent avoir les avantages
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui et faire une
comparaison avec ce qui existait dans le
passé
gravir l'échelle de la mobilité sociale
si importante pour les barbadiens est
passé aussi par l'évolution de la
construction des maisons locales qu'on
appelle chartrand zeze
aujourd'hui ces structures qui
hébergeait les familles les plus humbles
font partie du patrimoine architectural
du pays
nomo chatr signifiant biens mobiliers
qu'on pouvait transporter c'était facile
de démonter la maison classée des
éléments sur un camion il a transporté
un autre emplacement si vous achetez un
terrain par exemple vous pouvez élargir
la maison parce que le chat est là où
c'est une construction modulaire
des fonds gagnait de l'argent on a
ajouté des pièces certaines personnes
regardent de haut ces maisons qui se
trouvent principalement à la campagne
donc le but c'était de quitter le
château raoul progresser gagner de
l'argent et intégrer une société
d'abondance
dans les jardins du musée deux
étudiantes de la faculté rejette une
sonde de la guadeloupe déjeunent
ensemble
elles font stage musée pour
perfectionner leur niveau d'anglais
hébergés chez l'habitant de sujet de la
transition république est souvent
évoqués dans les discussions
barbadillo entre cros dix mille à la
perle des caraïbes
pour la couronne britannique est
effectivement c'était très attendue
parce que à leurs foyers y sont très
attachés encore à la couronne mais
attendre quand même une émancipation
entre guillemets vraiment une
indépendance totale donc ça sera
vraiment historique et je pense qu'on
est super heureuse et fière d'être ici
pour voir ça
l'hippodrome de barbade se situe au
coeur du garçonne un site classé
patrimoine de l'unesco il s'agit d'un
exemple d'architecturé britannique de
l'époque de l'empiré colonial
le blason de la monarchie est conservée
sur cet ancien tribunal militaire
devant les tribunes de l'hippodrome où
les passionnés de ce sport des rois
soutiennent leurs chevaux préférés se
dresse cette statue en bronze d'un grand
champion qui appartient à l'aristocratie
britannique
chaque matin depuis un siècle les
chevaux de course arrive pour travailler
sur la piste
les barbadiens adore les courses les
spectateurs sont tellement heureux
confié à des cours
on fait ça ici au gary sol depuis plus
de 100 ans
c'est notre culture c'est à nous
à madrid l'entraîneur de 35 chevaux
vérifie la santé de ces échanges et dont
nos jokers le programme de travail
il a gagné de multiples coups ça barbade
et à l'étranger ses cheveux sont souvent
plus rapide que les concurrents
européens américains et caribéens
le changement de statut de sony
l'inquiète tout comme la jeune étudiante
c'est devenu évident il lui manque des
précisions sur l'impact à la transition
en république
les autres pays de la caraïbe qui sont
devenus république ont eu beaucoup de
problèmes notre premier ministre maya
mots clés elle est très compétente et je
pense qu'elle sait comment faire mais
nous ne sommes pas allés je suis très
inquiet par rapport à nos relations avec
l'angleterre et d'autres pays
je ne sais pas à quel point on nous
aider dans le passé avant de devenir un
république mais c'est un petit pays et
on a besoin de toute l'aide qu'on peut
trouver on est dépendant du curieux
les traditions héritées de la
grande-bretagne et de la période de la
colonisation ont été adoptés et
transformé par les barbadiens
deux fois par semaine les chevaux de
course des socios la plage pour prendre
un bain de mer ce moment de détente
thérapeutique pour les animaux qui sont
d'excellents nageurs est aussi une
attraction touristique
les visiteurs peuvent s'approcher des
chevaux et échanger avec les liens sont
d'écurie
à barbade 80 % des visiteurs sont
britanniques
de passage en république ne va pas les
empêcher de retourner sur l'île
c'est ma première visite ici
j'aime les gens les vibrations la
nourriture je ne pense pas que
l'addition de changer de statut
influencé ma décision de revenir à mort
d'anne
lise est belle il ya tellement de choses
à faire et c'est notre troisième bédié
et nous allons y retourner c'est si beau
en effet la majorité des visiteurs
viennent profiter des belles plages et
de la mer turquoise de barbade
aujourd'hui ces éléments aussi vitaux à
la bonne santé du tourisme le pilier de
l'économie barbadienne sont menacées par
le réchauffement climatique qui a
provoqué la montée des eaux sur cette
île où le point le plus élevé n'atteint
que 340 m
votre altesse invités distingué
pendant notre tournage mais à modeler
premier ministe de barbade était en
écosse peau participer à la côte 26 la
conférence sur le changement climatique
elle a exhorté les pays riches à
respecter leurs engagements envers les
pays en voie de développement dont la
lutte contre le réchauffement de la
planète
lauzoua va à ceux qui ont des yeux pour
voir à ceux qui ont des oreilles pour
écouter à ceux qui ont un coeur pour
ressentir ou survivre nous ne pouvons
pas supporter une augmentation de
température de plus de un degré et demi
2 degrés c'est une condamnation à mort
pour les habitants d'antigua-et-barbuda
des miles et la dominique et fidji pour
le kenya et le mozambique
et oui pour les habitants de samia
et de barbarie
nous ne voulons pas de cette
condamnation à mort nous sommes venus
ici aujourd'hui pour vous dire redoutent
les bruits forts
l'érosion côtière conséquence de la
montée des eaux est visible tout au long
de la côte ouest de l'île où la
concentration des hôtels est la plus
forte
au parc marin de foxton une zone qui
fait partie d'un plan gouvernemental
pour inverser l'érosion des tonnes de
rochers ont été déposés sur les plages
pour piéger le sable
gare your eyes sauveteurs dont la
station de foxconn a grandi sur cette
côte
quand j'étais jeune on avait beaucoup de
plages propres des longues ça n'existe
plus
on voit de plus en plus de roche dans la
mer
ainsi les gens préservent leur propre
plage on voit les clients sur la plage
c'est parce qu'on leur a vendu le sable
le soleil c'est la plage mik
malgré un mur de protection
le restaurant de cet hôtel est menacé
par les vagues au loin un nom jeunes des
pauses d'immenses rochers dans la mer
pour construire une digue une tentative
pour ralentir les effets de l'érosion
sur la plage les traces d'anciennes
digues et l'érosion autour des racines
des arbres des montres à l'avancé
inéluctable de l'eau sont les plages les
touristes pourraient bien choisir une
autre destination
la majorité des personnes qui viennent
ici soient attirés par les plages le
bouton et la nourriture quand on fait
notre promenade matinale on aime bien
marché sur les plages donc s'il n'y a
plus de sable ça va affecter nos
habitudes et notre expérience
touristique
plus au nord en six semaines un village
de marins-pêcheurs le sable a disparu il
y a trente ans à cet endroit il y avait
trois rangées de maisons sur une plage
large de 16 mètres la mère à tout prix
les habitants ont dû être relocalisés
l'industrie de la pêche a été anéantie
auparavant une trentaine d'embarcations
était ancré dans cette baie
selon les anciens le village aurait
perdu 40% de sa population à cause de
l'érosion côtière
il s'agit d'un mélange de d'érosion
côtière et de la construction sur les
plages ou installés par exemple et
marina
plusieurs digues ont été construites
c'est pour retenir le sable par des
propriétaires qui ont beaucoup
les habitants de cinq semaines n'ont pas
assez d'argent pour construire leur
propre et digues
omar ben est l'un des derniers à marin
pêcheur à travailler ici
célibataire sans enfant à change ils
peuvent faire face plus facilement aux
incertitudes de son métier qui à son
tour subi des effets du changement
climatique
ce n'est pas si mal que ça dès qu'on
trouve les clients c'est ok pour moi a
travaillé dur sur l'océan avec l'espoir
d'attraper quelque chose je reviens je
vends ici comme ça que je gagne ma vie
sur la plage de carolles halle près de
ridgetown le bnd meurt à la fin de la
journée fait partie des habitudes et
barbadien si fiers de leur identité et
de leurs traditions
la prospérité de la république de
barbade et de son peuple est
intrinsèquement lié à la bonne santé de
l'environnement de plus en plus
fragilisé par le changement climatique
et par les activités de l'homme autour
des zones côtières